Republican senator Ted Cruz published
two tweets condemning a law in Uganda
that punishes homosexuality with the
death penalty and his base was furious
with him this is when the monster you
created gets completely out of your
control Ted Cruz tweeted this Uganda law
is horrific and wrong that's true any
law criminalizing homosexuality or
imposing the death penalty for
aggravated homosexuality is grotesque
and an Abomination that's true all
civilized Nations should join together
in condemning this human rights abuse
that is also true and many of his own
followers turned on him not necessarily
saying we should be putting gay people
to death but saying Ted aren't there
more important issues to talk about
you're not going woke are you you're not
a groomer are you this is the epitome of
the monster you created getting out of
control